Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism
is brought to you by a new sponsor.
So listen up folks.
This is a good one because have you ever
wanted to be as powerful as a mullet
wearing Ninja from an 1880s movie or as
flamboyant as big gay Al Big Al in south
park or as sleek as a black panther
in the Amazon on the hunt? Well,
there's great news because I've been
testing this product that you wrap around
your genitals and it makes you feel
like a superhero and it is called
[inaudible].
I've spent the last two to three weeks
traveling with underwear from these guys
and they are comfy.
I got to tell you,
it feels like a Geisha has giving your
groin a hug and it's not just for dudes.
But if you go to [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim, that's m, e e, u n d,
I e s.com,
forward slash Tim,
you can see all of the underwear
that I've been wearing.
There's some pretty ridiculous ones. And,
uh, I will also highlight my favorite,
you'll probably be able
to guess which it is.
These underwear made from micro model,
which is extruded from Austrian
beechwood trees in the Alps. Yes. Fancy.
And it's two times softer than cotton,
scientifically tested using the collar
bottom method developed in Kyoto.
And you know, those Japanese very
crafty. And, uh, I will say a few things.
Number one, if you go to [inaudible]
dot com forward slash Tim,
you get to see all of these spectacular
underwear that I've been wearing and I
am a bit of an underwear connoisseur,
socks, fashion, sense with sweat pants,
not so much underwear. I
understand. So check them out.
And if you go to [inaudible]
dot com forward slash Tim,
you will also be able to see lots
of hot ladies wearing me undies,
female underwear.
And that's just a lot of goodness for
both the men and the women out there.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
I love these underwear and a,
I'm going to be packing tonight probably
six to 12 pair to take with me to
Australia. They're great. Check them out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99
designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything
from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that
led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York
Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers
from around the world and here's how it
works. Whether you need a t
shirt, a business card, a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and
designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches
and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an
original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have
already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some
of my competitions,
some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show,
ladies and germs where it as my job to
deconstruct world class performers to
tease out the habits,
routines, influences,
et cetera that you can apply
to your life and those experts.
The world class performance range from
hedge fund managers to actors like Arnold
Schwarzenegger,
to people like General Stanley McChrystal
to chess prodigies and everyone in
between.
And in this case we have a business icon,
none other than the oracle of
Silicon Valley. That's Reid Hoffman.
He's referred to as the Oracle Silicon
Valley by a lot of tech insiders who look
at his company building and investing
track record, which includes for instance,
well of course paypal, linkedin,
but then Facebook, airbnb,
flicker and on and on
with awe and rightly so.
Read is co founder and
executive chairman of Linkedin,
which has more than the 300 million users.
Before that he was executive vice
president at paypal which was purchased by
Ebay for one point $5 billion.
There he was nicknamed firefighter in
chief by the CEO who is Peter Teal who's
also been on this podcast noted venture
capitalists. David Z says of Reed.
He is arguably the most successful angel
investor in the last decade or past
decade and they're both now
partners at Greylock partners.
He has a track record to envy and in
this podcast he is joined by a friend.
He's joined by Michael McCollough,
MD who's also co founder
of questbridge.org and a
successful investor of his own
right with training as an er physician.
Michael is political professor at UCF
and previously served as the on call er
physician for the Dalai Lama.
Michael is also a road scholar,
Kauffman fellow and a showcase a fellow.
He is an avid meditator and is
particularly interested in investing in
technologies and companies
pertaining to the mind.
So we bounced around a
lot in this conversation.
We covered a ton including how Reid met
Mark Zuckerberg for the first time and
how he decided to invest in Facebook,
lots behind that firefighting and started
beyond using board games to develop
strategy reads view of what Uber has done
well and what they could improve upon.
Some of read suggested
philosophers for entrepreneurs,
we talk about going off algorithm per
se in the Er to manage life and death
decisions, the three types of Ceos and
much, much more. It is a very dense,
intense and useful episode and of course
we discuss questbridge as reading and I
are both on the advisory board.
Questbridge guys have to check it out.
[inaudible] dot org currently supplies
more exceptional low income talent,
meaning kids to top universities
than all other nonprofits combined.
Questbridge has created a single
standardized college application that's
accepted by 36 or so top universities
like Stanford, MIT, Amherst and Yale.
This allows them to do some very,
very clever and innovative things such
as giveaway laptops and the giveaway
forms,
double his college applications.
This offers scholarships to many kids
who might otherwise not even think of
college. So if you want to
break the cycle of poverty,
questbridge is easily one
of the most fascinating,
effective and highly leveraged tools
I've ever seen. So check it out.
[inaudible] dot org we
will talk more about that.
So please check out the show notes.
There are a lot of cool
show notes for this episode,
four hour workweek all spelled out.
Just go to four hour work
week.com and click on podcast,
all the book recommendations,
et Cetera. And uh,
you can find a lot more there about
everything that we talk about.
So without further ado,
please enjoy this conversation
with the Oracle Silicon Valley,
Reid Hoffman and Michael McCullough
read. Michael, welcome to the show. Great
to be here. Thank you for having us, Tim.
I'm thrilled.
I'm really excited to have you guys on
and I know you've both known each other
for some time and I was thinking
about the commonalities that,
that you might have the
common threads and uh, we'll,
we'll certainly come back to this,
but I had heard Peter Teal had said,
have you read that you are the
firefighter in chief at paypal?
And I think that,
uh,
Michael certainly based on
our conversations at least
certainly is exhibited
tremendous firefighting qualities.
So we'll come back to that.
But I thought we could begin with
just some basic context for folks and,
uh, repress. We could start with you.
When people ask you the question,
what do you do?
How do you answer that?
Well, there's a short
answer and the long answer,
the short answer is I'm an
entrepreneur and investor.
That's what I want to be very quick
and move through the question.
The long answer is I essentially a build
design and improve human ecosystems
through software, either
as a creator or as a, uh,
an ester and partner. And what that
means is everything from, you know,
things like paypal to Linkedin,
to airbnb.
Each of these things are ways that
you craft how people find each other,
how they interact with each other,
how they establish their identity and
how they make progress in their lives.
And that's part of what I mean by
building and improving human ecosystems.
I love it. Uh, Michael, what, what
about yourself? You, you wear many hats,
but how would you answer that question and
these days? Yeah, I'd say it's probably
pretty similar. I'm, I'm uh, uh,
I create and I help people
create things, uh, uh,
entrepreneurial investor as well.
But I'm an er physician by training
and actually began my life in,
in reverse from most people kind of
creating a non profits actually first.
So I made eight nonprofits
before my first accompany,
including like angel investments and
things like, you know, heartflow and such.
And I'm, uh, currently a partner at,
I can remember going to healthcare
and, uh, that's, uh, I'd love to bridge
just on the medical side of things.
Uh, Michael, you'd a very, uh,
difficult beginning so to speak. And
that is going way back to birth. I was,
I was hoping you could just give us a
brief description of your experience at
birth.
Sure.
It's interesting how sometimes small
little slips from like an intern or like a
resident can alter your life. Where I
was eight weeks premature, uh, with,
uh, uh, twin birth. And, um,
basically it's a little too hard on my
head and it hemorrhage and it was missed
for nine years, so I couldn't speak
much until I was about in high school.
I couldn't speak as fluent as I
am now till I was in my thirties.
And even even like right now I have it
like a speech impediment device kind of
like they have in the king's
s uh, uh, speech movie,
always speak in accents if I need
to speak more fluently. Uh, so, uh,
for me I learned how like watch people
a lot when I was younger cause it was
harder for me to interact
with them kind of properly.
Got It. And, uh, the as, as the lines, uh,
for both of you started converging
and, uh, but before you met Reid,
you went to, as I understand
it, a somewhat unconventional
high school in Vermont,
I think it was the Putney school where
you farm to Maple Syrup and drove oxen.
Uh, what did you, what did you take from
that experience that stuck with you,
if anything?
Well, I was actually a, uh, at
the time, you know, it's funny,
it's kind of was your older,
each decade you look back on your life
and you actually in fact have a different
view of your early decades.
So if you'd asked me 10, 20
years ago, it's like, well,
it's completely off track.
I've become a technologist
and entrepreneur or none of
that stuff was actually a
directly relevant to now when I kind
of look back at it. And I said, well,
actually in fact it was very
grounding. Um, I had experiences,
there are everything from black smithing
to actually a bunch of artistic things.
Um, I had, you know,
kind of some intensity around cross
country speed skiing and sports and all of
that actually I think helped me
understand the breadth of human condition.
You know, typically, um, silicon
valley entrepreneurs and,
and, and, uh, investors and,
and technologists tend
to be very narrow focus.
And I actually think it's helped
me keep a broader focus, uh,
as I think about kind of what it is
to be human and how do we increase our
humanity.
And I might be skipping
ahead a little bit,
but do you have then a
sympathetic ear for say,
nontechnical founders who come in without
technical chops a or how do you look
at that?
Well, so I um, it depends
on the project. Um,
some pro or depth of technology.
Usually when I talked to a non technical
founder who wants to create something,
I,
the very second and third piece of
advice I give them is to find a technical
cofounder. Uh, because you know, it's not,
you know, it's not so easy to just say,
oh,
well I'm going to hire some engineers
and some remote location to build the APP
that I think of because actually in fact,
you have to be much more detailed,
much more specific
about how it's evolving.
And so if you're building technology
and you don't at least have a, uh,
a good tech technical cofounder, you
have a problem. Now that being said,
there's a number of,
of businesses that, um,
the technology is only one compete.
It's an important piece,
but it's only one piece. Like airbnb for
example. You know, Nate's very technical,
but Brian and Joe, our design
folks, their product folks,
there are folks, um, they
both, you know, kind of, uh,
coming out of [inaudible] and so,
and actually that helps fundamentally
with the airbnb product.
And so it isn't that you then,
it isn't that everybody in a
founding team has to be technical,
but if you're doing the technology thing,
at least one of you does.
Right. No, that makes perfect sense.
Where did philosophy
enter the picture for you?
Because I know a lot of people in
Silicon Valley think of you in part as a
philosopher, a at least a
thinker along those lines. Ha.
How did you become interested
in philosophy and why?
Well, it's funny actually and very, uh,
I'd say one of the small
critiques of Silicon Valley is it,
this may actually speak more to you
than the people of Silicon Valley.
A very few people in Silicon Valley
interface with me as a philosopher.
It takes up another thinker, like you
would actually ask that question. But, um,
the way that I got to it is I did my
undergraduate at Stanford University in,
along with Michael and, um,
my undergraduate degree was
called symbolic systems,
which is in short speak cognitive
science and artificial intelligence.
And,
uh,
I've always actually been very interested
in kind of what makes us uniquely
human and, and, uh,
and that's continued throughout my
entire arc of my career in childhood.
And so then it was like the scientific
study of, of thought and language.
But then what I realized when I was
at Stanford is that actually in fact,
even though we were trying
to be scientific about what
it is to be intelligent
about what it is to communicate about
what it is to have a point of view on the
world, um, the science hadn't
really gotten there yet.
And actually in fact, uh,
I should experiment with
philosophy to figure out the,
the whether or not the,
the,
the rudiments of understanding these
things I could get out of philosophy in
order to pursue a more
scientific view of intelligence.
And so, uh, because the modern analytics,
a view on philosophy is it's pre science.
It's like how you think about
things with precision. Uh, uh,
and then science births out of philosophy.
And so I went to Oxford in order to,
uh,
study philosophy.
Are you currently drawn to any particular
schools of philosophy or philosophers
in the context,
say recommending someone who has never
been exposed to philosophy or fuels that
they haven't? Uh, what, what
starting points might you suggest?
Well, one of the things that
I, uh, the papers that I
read at, cause it's a, you'd,
when you do a course, you read a subject,
one of them was that can shine. And so,
uh, one of the things I
actually frequently, uh,
refer people to when they're thinking
about kind of how do we think of ourselves
as, as, as,
as sharing a world as talking to each
other about it as understanding it.
A matter of fact,
I recently,
when I was explaining a theory on Bitcoin,
uh,
to some fellow technologist, I said, look,
it's like a can Justinian language game,
right? That the notion of how you
play it. And they're like, okay,
how do I understand that? I'm like, okay,
well here's some good books on Vic can
shine and here's a couple of points.
Right? Um, but it is,
that would be the one that
I would probably start with
just because I think he
is one of the, you know, um,
one of the fundamental philosophers who
is still being understood because the,
the, the, the,
the kind of one of the bedrocks of modern
analytic philosophy is to think of of
if you're trying to talk to someone else
about some problem and you trying to
make progress,
how do you make language as
positive and instrument as possible?
And what are the ways that language can
work and what are the ways that language
doesn't work? And so for
example, on that, on that thread,
when I wrote my thesis in Oxford,
it was on thought experiments because
most philosophers actually in fact analyze
and argue through thought experiments.
And there's actually more
limitations in the methodology then,
at least many belief.
No, it's, it's uh,
I find language just an
endlessly fascinating topic
because you, you'll find,
I mean,
silicon valley and elsewhere,
people will debate say the existence
of God without ever defining, uh,
what God is for each of
the parties involved.
So Michael, well, you
and I have spoken about,
I suppose philosophical topics a
lot about meditation. Uh, and, uh,
I think people gravitate towards say
religion or philosophy respectively to too
often face the prospect
of death or mortality.
I would love you to
elaborate if you could, uh,
about going off algorithm in the Er and
what that means because I've had some
fascinating conversations with you about
this and I was hoping you might be able
to just explain that and give a few
examples. Sure. Well, I, I think,
I think algorithms
protect a lot of people,
particularly from,
um,
if physicians aren't being fully
attentive or on top of all the literature,
but in within a bell curve there that
might be ways to save people or even
improve people's lives that, that in kind
of the standard operating procedures.
So like I had a patient one time who
came in with headed to a burns and,
and you can look at him and you would
know once you intubate him and have him in
the ICU, he, he wouldn't
possibly actually wake up again.
But he was lucid enough and I thought,
you know,
I don't want to call a few people
before I had to go to sleep.
So I gave him my cell phone to
you as much to their chagrin of,
and the people in the room,
um,
better make a few calls.
But even even there,
like I had to stop them from making
additional calls but he got to call a few
people. Uh, he had begun
to swell as airway shirt,
so I had to make sure I could
intubate on kind of the first try or,
or a pub would have lost my job.
But um,
and by intubate you may get a
tube down his trachea. Yeah,
completely closed. Yeah. Cause if you in
inhale hot air, then you're,
the, the soft tissue in,
in your kind of, your mouth will swell
up and you won't be able to breathe.
Now in, in, in his case,
it didn't change outcome that much cause
he was either going to a die in the er
or in the ICU. So, so I thought
enabling him to make kind of a human,
a connection ahead of the ICU would be,
would be helpful.
And now in,
in uh,
in your experience then
when you look at the,
let's just define maybe the use of
the word algorithm. So is it, is it,
is it fair to say that in this context
one could think of an algorithm as a
mandatory checklist, which also
excludes certain options? Yeah,
I think a few, and I think a tool,
a guanine work and other shows,
a checklist is profoundly helpful.
Checklist Manifesto. Yeah,
it's really good book.
And,
and even things like washing your hands
between patients with things as simple
as that will save water lives.
However,
sometimes you do know everything on the
checklist and sometimes there are things
you can do that aren't on the checklist
that actually ought to be done. So, um,
example was also that,
um,
I had a patient who,
in our ear or they have a policy of
making sure they call their donor network
after the patients actually passed away
to see if they can with the permission
of the family and the, to the
patient, um, help with us,
uh, skin transportation or like a cornea.
But they became confused to think,
well,
that means you then you shouldn't call
earlier to talk about the heart or the
liver and things like that.
So in that particular case,
in an algorithm or a policy, actually, um,
make people not appreciate
the more important organs
to kind of think about too.
So, uh, have answered your, uh,
no, no, you have and I just,
when we've had dinner before and um,
I'd love for you to describe if you could,
and it's a,
it was, it was fascinating for me to
hear and your, your description of this,
but what is it like to,
and I know we're bouncing around a bit,
but to stare into someone's eyes or to
look into their eyes as they pass from
alive, not alive. Maybe
having that happen a few times.
And it's interesting cause it often
depends on the emotional state of,
of the patient, right? So
if the patient is afraid
you're trying to give comfort
to them is they're dying and,
and other times patients die and they're
giving you a sense of peace and kind of
universality that that would be hard to,
uh,
pay for kind of a depth of understanding
that they are dying and you know,
this is kind of the moment of
their death. And so, um, it,
it's an honor to be there or either way
to either like witness it happening from
a person who is a content with it or
to comfort and hope the hand of someone
who's not.
And uh, in that type of
context or just in general,
what in your mind separates a good er
physician from a great er physician?
What are the great people have, do or
not do that the, that the good, uh,
lack,
yeah, I think a good or for this
and it's thorough. You know,
they make sure they don't like needlessly
missed anything. We're not like,
you know, wash their hands
between the patients. I think, um,
if you are layer on to that and that
you actually care about the patient,
you know, you, you like to like
laugh could be alcoholic or to make,
um,
or to help the dorm in the first trimester
of her pregnancy feel comfort that
she is, you, you're likely
not to lose her child.
But even if she does,
it wouldn't interfere with her being
able to get pregnant in the future again.
And so you could either pay
attention to say the odds that,
that she'd lose this particular pregnancy
or to make sure to reassure her what
she's actually worried about is, you
know, will I ever have an infant,
will ever have a family?
And I think, um, like,
like a lot of people don't know that a
third of all pregnancies are actually
lost.
And that's normal for humans.
Every animal has like a normal
weight of like losing one.
And that's a known a pregnancy.
So it's lacking more like half.
And yet, since we no longer live
in a tribes with other people,
we hide the fact of losing an
infant in the first trimester.
So if you don't take the extra
time to a comfort people,
sometimes they think they're
normal when they actually are not.
Right.
No,
that makes perfect sense.
I don't think that applies to therapy
of all different types. I mean,
outside of the context of
an emergency room, the uh,
the firefighting that I
mentioned earlier, uh, read it.
My understanding was that you had, you
were many, many different hats and uh,
had the,
the,
the role of interacting with a lot
of external entities when at paypal,
whether that was regulatory
or the credit card processors,
maybe that's not the right
description of them, but, uh,
what makes a good entrepreneurial
firefighter in a context like that?
Or what, what did your coworkers
feel made you good at that?
Well,
the most to relevant
factors where Peter Teal,
who was the CEO feeling when I was
good and solving the problems, uh,
everything else was, was a secondary
to those two considerations.
I mean the, um, on the firefighting
side, I mean, paypal had, uh,
perhaps the most,
um,
the most kind of a parallel thing to,
you know, to date myself a little
bit like a star wars, you know,
flying into the trench and trying to
actually hit the target and a lot of
different ways you could, you
could fail. And, and so in, in,
in the paypal case, for
me, a lot of that was,
um,
uh,
building an understanding of what
each particular problem particularly
throughout was,
what the key moving a variable was and
then being able to solve that and then
propagate that out to all of the places.
So, you know, for example, one of the,
um, the kind of challenges
that Peter handed to me was,
um, we had thought that
paypal might be a bank.
And so we had started the process
of applying for a banking license.
Then what we discovered and decided upon
inference was that actually in fact,
banking regulation is so fierce
in terms of not innovating,
not building new things.
It would be very difficult to
build a new company on that basis.
So I essentially had to move to,
um,
to go persuade the
regulators that it was okay.
That even though we had applied
for a banking license, right,
uh,
that we,
it was okay that we were not going to
be a bank and that and that it wasn't a
tell that was we'll just inconvenient
for us or anything else. And,
and to give to full
color to this, the, the,
the basic statement about
whether or not a, a,
a company as a bank starts with the claim.
You accept deposits, which obviously
if anyone has, has exposure to paypal,
they said, well, you could frame what
paypal does as accepting deposits,
right? You know, uh, why
is it you're not a bank?
And so that would be the kind of
challenge, uh, that was handed to me.
And then what you had to do is you
had to figure out for this, uh,
problem, which could kill the company.
What were the key moving variables,
learn them,
talk to really smart people and then
solve that problem so that it was then
fundamentally part of the
cornerstone of what you are doing. A,
and it ranged from relationship
with Ebay to visa and mastercard to
international. Right. And we just,
uh, just a very long list of things.
And um, and each one, the, the, the, the,
the looking at the problem
had to be reframed.
It was almost like building a kind of a,
a view of the world.
And then what are the key moving parts
in order to get right in order to make
people succeed.
And when you were defining
the moving variables, uh,
is that a list of the unknowns that where
you need to go seek out information or
is it, uh, how,
how would you go about putting
together that list? Well,
it kind of starts with a,
what is the end result that you
want to have happen? So for example,
uh, and, uh, like in regulatory
one, the key thing is that,
uh, you can't, regulators will
never tell you that they can't,
that that is not their job to regulate
you because there's no interest on that
for that. Well, they will simply
do is say, oh, actually, in fact,
there's nothing for me here to actively
regulate. They won't tell you, I won't,
you know, you're outside of my
scope. They'll go, ah, okay, fine.
You now seem like you're an okay.
Like I don't need to actually regulate
you because you're not in my positive
probate. And so you say, okay,
how did you get that state of affairs
and how do you propagate that?
And then you start working
back from that to say, okay,
well how would they make their judgments?
What are their key considerations? Uh,
how can I learn about that?
Who would I need to know?
Cause those were some of
the unknowns come in. Uh,
what are the kinds of things
that would get them to say, okay,
uh, you're, you're, you're, uh,
I think you're being reasonable
and within my per view of how,
of how I am out to help govern society,
help tech to consumers,
uh, help protect other entities.
Uh, you're good by me and that,
and then you, then you work back from that
is the, essentially the way you do it.
And how did you learn how to do that?
Uh, were, were you part of a debate
team? You studied negotiation?
Did you work at a State Fair
for the summers? I mean,
how did you develop the ability to,
the ability to not only
deconstruct a problem like that,
but then to interface with all these
various stakeholders at the table?
I think the most fundamental was
I, uh, I dunno if, if you're,
uh, audience, uh, knows what this is a,
you probably do as a child,
I played a lot of Avalon hill board games.
Uh,
and each board game is actually a
complex set of rules and circumstances.
And essentially as you're analyzing each
one of them, you kind of look back from,
okay,
these goals mean that these are the kinds
of moving parts and how do you do it?
So it was actually in fact my childhood
gaming for being able to build a model
of what a game was.
That was the,
essentially the fundamental thing that
informs, you know, my strategic sense.
Um,
because this all comes out of strategy.
And if,
if you were giving advice to say someone
leaving Stanford Undergrad and they
had, they had no gaming
background, how might,
what would you recommend they do to
try to develop a strategic ability?
We're thinking,
well, um, you know, there's a
lot of different paths to it.
Most people think they're better
at strategy than they are. Um,
and so you really have to actually
really hold up a very clear,
you have to have a very
deep self awareness of am I
in fact really good at it?
Because like having an idea or
saying like for example, you said,
well I'll just do this.
Well one move,
a real strategy is actually
built up off a, you know,
what are your competitors doing? What
is their mindset? What are their assets?
How are they going to move, how you're
going to move, what are your, uh,
what are your edges? What's the
way that you could make that work?
How is it when they're playing against
you, you can still play to win. Um,
so games are very good way to do that.
And getting a lot of different exposure
to computer games cause computer,
you know,
AI strategies are usually
not that interesting but
against other people is very
useful.
I think it's also useful to read some,
uh, which I did as a child,
you know, military strategy,
some zoo von Clausewitz, other
sorts of folks, more modern folks.
And to think about kind of like what are
the set of principles that when you're
thinking about how to,
how to win a game that's in,
in contention in conflict. And then a
lot of people also of course have some,
um, sports knowledge on this
too. Although one of the things,
it's frequently a little
limiting on sports is that, uh,
the sports game that a person tends to,
they tend to be like, I play soccer,
I played football,
I played basketball.
And then they have a very deep
sense of what the strategy is there.
But they haven't played enough different
kinds of games and have different
circumstances. You know, it's um, uh,
it's like understanding like, well,
what happens if I change these four
rules in basketball? Right, right.
How would you play the strategy now,
you know,
totally that that's the kind of
thing because actually in fact,
most of the circumstances you find
yourself in actually, in fact,
you have to figure out what is the
current game look like and how do you play
that. Uh, and that's of
course also by the way,
the reason why frequently, um, you know,
companies rise and fall is because
they learned to play one game,
they got good at it and
then the marketplace changes
and now it's a new kind of
game and you have to adjust
the playing that new game.
And that's actually in fact a part of
recognizing when a strategy applies.
Absolutely. Yeah, it'd been,
I was just having a conversation with
someone about the rise and fall of Codec,
um, yesterday. And of
course this is sort of the,
the disruptive theme that one encounters
so much in silicon valley. I, um,
I, I, I wasn't planning on asking
this, but I'd be so curious to hear,
given your experience with
regulatory risk and so on, what,
what do you feel,
uh,
if you have an opinion Uber has
done well and what could they have,
uh, executed more
effectively or strategically?
So what they've done well is essentially
quickly deploying their product so that
it's clear that there's a bunch of
people who are benefiting from it. Uh,
both consumers and drivers,
uh, in various circumstances.
So that there is an ecosystem of
people by what you go look, see,
we can actually add a lot
of positive to the system.
I think that's been kind of one of the
things that they've done most positively
within it. On the negative side, you know,
the company tends to be
very combative and you know,
when you actually think about the
mental space in which regulators, um,
tend to operate,
they tend to have gone into that job
because they view themselves as protectors
of important groups in society,
whether they're consumers
or workers or other folks.
And so they don't tend
to respond very well.
It's not a competitive game with them.
It's not you bulldoze
through them or over them.
They're actually in fact what what they
want is they want to know that their,
their concerns are being answered.
And it's frustrating of course
for the company because you know,
the regulators are being triggered by
you know, a competitive interests like,
you know, taxi cab companies
and other kinds of things,
which I want the world to
stay only exactly as it is,
which is not actually good for
anyone to just say, you know,
the way that we had to run is the way
that we were running in the 1950s and
that's the way we're going to
be running in 3000. You know,
that's obviously not a very good idea.
So actually in fact,
innovation and change and the pushback
as frustrating. But nevertheless,
when you're interfacing
with the regulators, uh,
you have to interface with them
with the understanding that there,
that may be conservative, they may be
slow to change and maybe risk averse,
but their goal is a mission
of protecting society.
And she should interface with them on
that channel more than on the just get out
of my way. I'm innovating all right, and
treat you like I treat a competitor. Uh,
and that's, that's, that creates
a lot of unnecessary friction.
Right. No, that makes
sense. You are of course,
considered a company builder.
Uh,
you've had a integral part in
building some massive successes,
but you're also very well
regarded as an investor. And, uh,
I would love if you could tell the
story of getting introduced to mark
Zuckerberg and how you decided to be one
of the first investors in Facebook.
Well,
actually I could have told you I was
interested in investing in Facebook even
before, um, Mark Zuckerberg.
I track the product.
I thought it was extremely well done.
Uh, when I tracked it, it, you know,
he and his cofounders,
Dustin, Chris and others, uh,
or, uh, in, uh, Boston, you
know, going to Harvard. Right.
And so I want to ask too much about it.
I was,
angel investing is too much of a
hassle as a venture capitalist.
I probably would have flown out there,
but I was like, it was an angel,
too much of a hassle. And so I
kind of went, oh, that's cool.
And then went back to it and then I got
this call from Sean Parker who I'd known
from his work at Plaxo and you know,
it was a good product and venture and
good systems thinker on these things.
And Sean's had a, I've just met,
um, uh, these really good guys,
you know,
Mark Zuckerberg and others who are doing
this thing on Facebook that I'm joining.
That's really awesome. And I'm like, oh,
that's really cool. You moving to Boston?
And he's like, no, no, they're
here. And I'm like, oh,
that's interesting. He's like,
yeah, and we're looking for
it. That's when I'm like,
I would definitely like to
meet with them. Um, you know,
I'm super interested in this. Uh, I tend
to think, and one of the things I said,
which is I think totally,
you know,
even though it's probably
the most expensive economic
decision I've made in my
life, um, but it all in a good outcome.
I said, look, you know, when I did,
when I led the series a in French or a,
I got a lot of pushback on am I
having my cake and eating it too.
Cause even though I don't see any
conflict between Friendster and Linkedin,
you know,
it just generated all this stuff.
And part of having integrity and having,
you know,
a high sense of ethics is not just having
it but also making some work to appear
to have it.
So actually I think we should do is
we should have Peter a lead there.
Peter Teal lead the round and I'll follow
because then Peter can be the board
member. And even though I'm
super interested in this,
I think that's probably the best
thing to happen. And so, um,
my actually very first meeting was
Zuckerberg was at Peter teals office, uh,
uh, with Sean there who I'd known
and with, um, with, uh, CSEC.
And then Matt Cohler was there as well.
And who was working for me at the time.
And, uh, that was our very
first meeting. But you know, uh,
basically the meeting was
very confirmatory because
they'd already seen the
product, already know the
product, what are the amazing,
already seen it having traction. Um, and,
and really what I learned from the, from
the meeting, which is hardly a surprise,
especially now in retrospect,
was the Zuckerberg extremely smart,
very much of a learning machine.
Uh, very good at, uh, um,
you know, the evolution of
technologies. Um, and so,
but I'd already more or less was
positive, you know, if he'd said,
I don't want to meet with you,
but when you want to put in money,
I probably would have put in
money anyway. Right. And, uh,
did you, what was the, what was
mark Pincus his role at that,
at that point or his involvement
with Facebook? Uh, well, it actually,
so the way mark had also,
Pincus had also known Sean Parker
back from Napster days. Um,
uh, pig us had done a, an early
startup called freeloader.
But a part of actually how mark got
involved in the Facebook investment was
separately mark and I had bought
a patent called the six degrees.
Pat Seems has some number which describes
the viral expansion of a system.
And, uh, and you know, again, kind
of on the, on the AEC space, this,
I went, look, mark and
I are partners on this.
We're actually trying to protect all
these new web 2.0 viral companies.
That's our principal goal in this patent
in, in going and buying this patent.
But you know, um, uh, you know,
given that Facebook's also in this,
I should act in fact a split
the investment with mark, uh,
because, uh, you know, basically, um, uh,
it's part of being a good partner with
him. And so that's part of how mark now,
he also had known Shawn Parker and Shawn
had talked to him about it as well.
So there's,
there's a bunch of different things,
but that's fundamentally
how pink is also became a,
a series a investor in Facebook.
Got It. And on the, on
the, um, the decision,
or maybe it's not related at all,
but the um,
the suggestion that Peter Lead the round,
uh,
it's the impression of some people that,
that you have actively
decided in the past not to be,
to take the CEO role yourself.
Uh,
and do you,
have you sort of proactively made
decisions in your life to avoid being a,
to taking the CEO role or, or having
it for a long period of time and if so,
why is that the case or
is that a misperception?
Well,
there's kind of three different CEO jobs
at levels of scale and the organization
as CEO jobs of,
call it 10 20 50%
organizations or CEO jobs have,
you know, hundreds to, you know,
like 150 to 500 people organizations
and then their CEO jobs have,
you know, over 500 people,
like a thousand or thousands.
I've always known that I'm fundamentally
not really interested in the CEO job
that the large scale CEO job,
when you're doing the large scale CEO job,
your primary responsibility,
you have to invite me the strategy.
You have to think about
the things the right way,
but you're probably problem primary
thing is the organization, you know,
having the right or a culture, having
the right structure, the organization,
the right people in it,
the right way of hiring new people,
the right way of empowering them,
even though you're making
kind of strategic decisions.
And there are people like Jeff Wiener
who are completely awesome at that and I
rather help them rather than
being doing that, uh, personally.
Then you get to the other to see our job.
So you get to the mid stage CEO job,
I'm okay doing that. It's not the
thing I'm most passionate about.
I actually prefer to work on,
you know, product a strategies,
firefighting things, um,
uh, business strategies, uh,
problem solutions.
I'm thinking about how to reconceptualize
strategy the entire business and
either myself or we're
working with people on that,
but I'll do that in order to make it work.
And then in the early stages,
I'm actually pretty perfectly
comfortable doing it.
It's not necessarily a job that
I say I walk, I must do it.
But being the CEO of a
10, 20, 50, you know,
even up to 100% organization,
I can do that just fine because then
you're still all kind of working on the
same problem.
It's less about how you build the org.
Obviously you have to build a very strong
team, but it's less about like, okay,
how do we take the org from a
hundred people to a thousand people?
It's actually much more
um, uh, like, okay,
how do we just solve these key
problems and that stuff I like to do.
So it isn't really a,
a specific don't want the CEO job except
in the very large scale. What it is is,
uh,
m I am,
I am only interested in the CEO job as
it's instrumental to something serious
that I want to accomplish.
And then as that organization grows,
wants not to be the CEO.
And you've had some experience,
uh, searching for Ceos, uh,
what should founders remember when looking
for someone to replace themselves or
things as you keep in mind? Well. So
the first thing is generally speaking,
founders should try to go, like I'm still
very active at linkedin. Uh, should,
she'll to try to go the entire course
of the company to the degree to which
they're passionate and can be useful.
And companies are always
stronger with founders,
more in the more connected
and committed to it. Um,
but that being said, sometimes you
go, look, my great skill set is,
you know,
a product or migrate Skillset
is evangelism or migrate
skill set is, you know,
something other than building
the scale organization,
in which case the fundamental way
you look at it is, and then so the,
the formal way that silicon valley
used to look at it, which is,
I wrote an essay about this,
it's published on my linkedin influencer
posts and all my, my sight, you know,
Reid hoffman.org.
But the funnel,
the way that Silicon Valley used to look
at this is like you bring in gray hair
and executive a person with management
scale. And by that you want those skills.
But actually in fact, I think
what you're, what you're,
who you're bringing in as a founder,
as you're bringing in a lake later stage
co founder and you bringing in a later
stage cofounder,
ideally who has scale skills,
who knows how to build scale organizations
is passionate about this one.
You know, has their identity
as closely tied or, or,
or nearly as closely tied to the
organization as you do. It's,
it's this specific mission is
something that they really care about.
They're not just like, oh, I'm a
hired gun, but actually in fact,
I'm a missionary on this as well.
And,
and then someone who would
partner with you very well,
and that's actually what you're looking
for. And so, uh, that's part of, you know,
the reason why Jeff Wiener has been so
successful linkedin is because, you know,
he cares about not just
scale organizations,
but how do you transform people's careers?
How do you demonstrate you can be
doing compassionate business and the
compassionate management is a high
performing a culture of a company. Uh,
how do you have people who are,
who have a culture of,
we make ourselves significantly
better every year? Um, you know,
how do you bring all of that? That's part
of what he actually really cares about,
which links, which, you
know, uh, which, uh,
is deeply tied to the linkedin mission.
Uh,
and so he cares what the organization,
he cares about the way he manages and
cares about the product at all as a, uh,
essentially a later stage cofounder. And
that's the kind of thing that you, uh,
you should be thinking about when you're
a founder and you're thinking, okay,
it's time for me to bring
in a nother person as a CEO.
Thank you. Michael. I,
you mentioned accents a
little earlier and, uh,
that you use accents in the Er often.
And I know you've mentioned to me before
southern is best and I was hoping you
can elaborate on that because
do you reckon struggle? But, um, no one,
when I hit my head injury as a
kid and brain surgery is, uh,
in the fourth,
fifth grade,
yours like looking for like
ways to be more fluent. So,
uh,
in speeches I talk like I'm a European,
it's a good accent for speaking,
but if I'm in the year I
took a gun from Alabama,
Georgia cause it's a good
accent for sick people.
You can almost like yell at them,
they don't think you're mad. So it's,
you can kind of raise the
volume of someone who is
hearing impaired pretty loud.
They don't make him mad at him and it
keeps the nurses also kind of humorously
enter attained as well.
And how has the er experience or the
skills developed or exhibited there
translated to the other things that
you've done in the nonprofits or,
or in the fall for profit?
Yeah,
investment world.
The Er particular has helped a lot
with my investing cause most of the
specialties interface with the Er and
enabled me to like reach into like
ophthalmology or a cardiology and
invest it in things like heartflow.
Um,
I can just pick up the phone and speak
to an eventual to hearts tuitions and
things like that. So, um, I think
from a decision making capacity, it,
it teaches you the importance of actually
making a decision because you don't
always have all the information you need,
but the stakes are high.
So I think there's a lot
of entrepreneurial kind of
a crossover there that can
also be helpful,
right? Making important decisions
with incomplete information. Well,
well, what also just the importance of
having actually a made a decision as well,
right? Because if you're
always kind of like waffling,
it's uh, something, you know,
nothing actually happened.
And you and I have talked
a lot about meditation,
but more broadly speaking,
the people listening are very interested
in morning habits and morning routines.
So I'd love to ask you guys
the same question. Let's
start with you Michael. Uh,
what does the first 60 to 90 minutes of
your day look like and what time does it
start? If we could get into
specifics, that would be great.
Sure. More recently, many I, I,
I used to fight at this kind of hour and
a half awake in the middle of the night
thing between two sleep cycle's not kind
of actually just kind of get up and do
like probably half an hour to an hour.
But I committed Taishan between like three
and 4:00 AM in the morning or foreign
five and that then hence me half an hour
of real clarity after that to kind of
think about kind of my day and
how I'd like to end up using it.
And what type of
meditation do you practice?
Uh,
there,
there are concentration and mindfulness
techniques that you can use it a pretty
common I think rather than
talk about the type of, I do,
I think a lot of the debate
between types of meditations,
kind of like the debate of kinds
of like weight lifting people do.
And I think the important thing is
that you actually dislike, you know,
lift the weights. Right. So, um, I,
I'm not convinced any one type of
mindfulness training is the superior to
another,
but clearly almost anyone
would be superior to actually
not actually doing it.
Do you have any opinion of neurofeedback?
I think generally,
even as an investor,
I think there's beginning to
be a commercial break down
between the interface of
um,
the brain and you see these,
the EEG feedback pieces of
equipment I think, or not,
not quite
as far along now as they should be,
but I think you're certainly seeing some
nursing applications with people better
taking,
uh,
the interface with the mind out of the
realm of religion and into the realm of
science and such. And I think, um, uh,
there even like a prep high
schools who are doing a controlled
experiments on mindfulness to see how
it affects homer Kendo performance and
things like that.
Yeah,
no,
definitely an Adam Gazzaley who was
also in this podcast at UCF is too,
except really interesting work with uh,
iPad based or tablet based
games for quantifying um,
progress in meditation and mindfulness
up read. What about yourself?
What are your morning rituals look like?
In an ideal day,
assuming you have control of your morning,
uh,
the first 60 to 90 minutes of your
day, what, what does, what does that,
what does that look like if you
had your sort of optimal recipe?
Well, I dunno or not, but, um, and I
also don't know how it interesting is,
but you know, most of my days are
pretty packed, uh, because of, you know,
responsibilities to
Greylock responsibilities,
the linkedin portfolio
companies as much well things.
So where my morning tends to be most
highly tuned to is what does a creative
problem that I've identified.
Uh,
either they like as something that I
was like, okay, I want to work on this.
I want to think about this, the night,
the day before that, before. It's like,
this is a key thing that I want to think
about a product design, a strategy,
a solution to a problem that one of my
portfolio companies just looking at the,
that sort of thing,
uh,
or I need to solve this thing creatively
for a meeting I'm having later today.
Like, I'm, uh, we're making a decision
at Greylock to invest in something. Uh,
you know,
a team is going to be pitching me or
there's gonna be some kind of business
development relationship between linkedin
or another of my portfolio companies.
And so the very first thing
I do when I get up, uh,
almost always is to actually sit down
and work on that problem because that's
when I'm freshest.
Um,
I'm not distracted by
like phone calls and,
and responses to things and so
forth. So I'll, I'll, I'll actually,
it's the most Tabula Rasa kind of
blanks like moment that I have.
And so I used that to
maximize my creativity on a,
on a particular project.
I'll do you usually do it
before I shower has frequently,
like if I go into the shower,
then I'll continue to think
about it as I'm doing it,
but I'll get it all fired up. Uh,
ideally I would have 60 minutes for that.
Some mornings I do a frequently,
it's like around 30, um,
just because of the press
of the day. And then, uh,
the next things that kinda
round out of it's only 30, um,
or a combination of a quick triage three
email to see if there's anything that's
a,
uh,
an emergency that's or kind of something
that's temporarily or otherwise
important, uh, that I need to
get on right away. Uh, and then,
uh, frequently, um, most of my,
during the workweek I almost always
have a business breakfast. Uh,
on some project could be anything
from a nonprofit, you know,
like Mozilla to a portfolio company or uh,
just a general meeting with someone
who's been recommended to me. Uh,
and then on the drive to that breakfast,
um, frequently I'll do a call.
That's kind of one cause it's
one of those, uh, usually, uh,
the days are so packed with meetings
at some of the, the, the, the,
it's the typically the only
real phone time I have.
And so if there's someone I need to
talk to a that is not co located,
that's usually when I called them.
Got It.
And when you're working on
that first creative problem,
is that something that you've put
in a notebook the night before?
Is it on a laptop? How are you storing
these problems and then working on them.
Um,
so we'll either be most commonly,
cause you know, I kind of grew up where
I was thinking by using a pen and paper.
Uh, most commonly I will a sketch to
few things, thought about a few things.
Uh,
it will be a salt know and usually it's
in the notion of how do
you solve this problem?
Like a little bit back to the thing where
you're talking about is like setting
up that framework, like a strategy, you
know, within a strategy of the game.
What are the kind of key
things that you know,
might be constraints on a solution or
might be the attributes of a solution and
what are tools or assets I might have.
Because part of what I'm trying to
do is I actually think, you know, Mo,
most of our thinking of
course it's subconscious,
is part of what I'm trying to do is allow
the fact that we have this kind of a
relaxation, rejuvenation
period and sleeping, uh,
to essentially possibly bubble up the,
the thoughts and solutions to it.
And so when I woken up,
not only am I kind of Tabula
Rasa, but I'm also, uh,
possibly primed for that. And so
then no, that's the way I do it.
Yeah, no, that makes perfect
sense. You've said before,
read that your network is your mentor
and that you learn from everyone in your
network. I'd love to just tick off a
couple of names of people I believe,
you know,
and here the first thing that comes to
mind in terms of what you learn or have
learned from them. Uh, you mentioned
earlier the CEO of Airbnb, Brian Chesky.
Uh, what would, what's the first
thing that comes to mind there,
Brian? Um, uh,
one of the things I paid that I thought
was an excellent focus from him is that
he, if he calls us seven star
design, which is, you know,
most review systems are, uh,
you know, go to five stars.
And so seven stars was a thinking about
the design at a much broader scope.
But the precise way of thinking about it
is what he came to realize that airbnb
is not just an online product. It's not
just the, uh, marketplace, a website,
but it's actually the whole
entire experience that you
have of going to the room
or apartment of checking in,
of staying there and of leaving.
And how do you actually, in fact, uh,
best design within your abilities
of doing a peer to peer marketplace,
that entire experience. And
so the way the, the, the,
the placeholder he uses for that is
this thinking of seven star design,
which is thinking through
each step of the experience.
And so I thought it was
a highly instructive and
something I know a use myself
use when I talk to other
people because, um, uh,
our product isn't just, the website
isn't just the mobile application.
It's the way that people are embedded in
the environment when they're using it.
And you should think through that as much.
You can,
even though you may have some very limited
ability to control other aspects of
it.
Hmm. Or shape. And, uh, what about, uh,
one of your partners at Greylock,
John Lilly?
So John is about as deep and
interesting as a technologist.
You get a foreign investor,
he puts together of both
the aspects of being very deeply
technical about platforms. I mean,
he was the CEO of Mozilla growing it to
being 20% of web browsers with also kind
of a design experience.
Like he is a consulting professor
at the Stanford School of design.
And so for me, you know,
part of the thing that, uh,
I get from John and I've learned from
John is to think about the intersection of
kind of user design with deep
technology and how, for example,
design patterns then shape deep
technology patterns and kind of the,
a set of different questions
that you'd ask about, look,
what's the structure of the design space
and does that inform the structure of
your technology space?
Um,
and so we talk about a whole
wide variety of technologies,
but those are the kinds of,
of mental and strategy and thinking
patterns that I've gotten honed to a fine
edge from John. Also a
hilarious guy. Very, yes.
Sharp sense of humor.
Yes.
What about your former coworker
now SpaceX, Tesla founder,
Elon Musk.
So Ilan obviously super smart,
obviously relentless, uh,
obviously thinking, you know,
like for example, the, the, the,
the old phrase, the sky's the limit.
That's too short free lawn, right?
You know, Mars and beyond. Um,
uh, the thing that I most learned
from Ilan is actually in fact,
um,
that so previous to Elan's
amazing successes with a
Tesla and SpaceX and solar
city, uh, I had come to learn that,
uh, that part of the business strategy
is to solve the simplest and easiest,
most valuable problem.
And it actually in fact,
part of doing strategies to
solve the easiest problem.
So part of the reason why you work
in software and bits is that they,
that Adams are actually very difficult.
You have, uh, sometimes real material,
you know, product development,
risk, inventory, risk,
material science, you know,
all these things that
makes Adam products harder.
And so if you can work
in the bits products,
it's a lot more valuable at
scales more quickly and so forth.
And all of that's true in terms
of the fact that, that it wasn't,
that that lesson I'd learned was false,
but what Ilan taught me
was actually in fact,
if you have a very deep
vision for something,
you're relentless and you choose
something that really matters,
that the competitors are in
fact really weak. Right? Right.
Like there are not actually in
fact, like for example, you know,
all of the rocket contractors,
um,
we're mostly focused on how do
they milk government contracts,
not on how do they build
new propulsion systems,
not on how do they take advantage
of the last couple of decades of,
of actual progress.
Um,
and so that actually
gave him a, uh, as, uh,
it's a very hard challenge. What he's
done is extremely compelling and,
and you know,
very few people could pull it off,
but that gives you a sufficient window
even when you're taking on a hard
problem. And that's actually one
of the things I learned from Ilan
and Juliana. kiva.org chairwoman. Yup.
What would you,
what would you say to that?
So Julie, um, now I
knew this already, but,
um,
but Julie is a very good model for this,
which is that you can
have someone who is a,
a worldclass entrepreneur,
uh,
Cirelli experience with it is a general
learner, has done enterprise, uh,
companies, uh, has transitioned
to thinking about open source,
um,
uh,
and was one of the early kind of people
of how to apply open source of things,
can also go and thoroughly apply
all of those things into a,
not just the for profit world,
not just her own companies,
not just her angel investments,
not just her work with areas
kind of incubators and others,
but also into the nonprofit world.
And where it's one of the
things when you say, you know,
we have a tendency and in
Silicon Valley to say, you know,
entrepreneurs are
heroes. Um, but you know,
one of the things I think is truly
heroic and awesome about what, uh,
Julie has done is, hey, look,
I can take all these skills I can
take my entire life only just building
economics and, and, and, and enterprise
businesses and other kinds of businesses.
But actually,
in fact,
when I begin to think about how do I
scale and how do I change the nature of
humanity and human ecosystems,
I'm going to take my technology skills
and apply them to philanthropic projects
with the same kind of scale,
with the same kind of impulse.
And I'll put real time into it.
I'm not just going to talk about it and,
uh,
and I'm going to do it with,
you know,
the full set of skills that a worldclass
entrepreneur does. And so, you know,
I've seen,
I've taken heart and
inspiration from Julie about,
uh,
the value of,
of diving in and getting your hands
dirty on projects that are outside of the
commercial side for,
uh,
that are really ones that you can
actually in fact get to massive scale.
And, uh, last last for this
list a US Senator Cory Booker,
who I actually met for the first
time at an event that you co hosted.
So thank you for that. But, uh, what,
what have you learned or admired, uh,
as it relates to Corey? Well, it's a,
Corey is I think a great civic.
Um, he, uh, you know,
is a entrepreneurial and bold himself
when he's was the mayor of Newark.
He lived in the housing projects in
order to know what the experience was in
order to be able to be,
to understand, you know,
kind of how does he maximize the
happiness and the economic potential
and the, and solve the problems of
the people that he is there to help,
you know, help as a mayor.
And then as a senator,
uh,
part of what I have found him
to be practically unique in,
in like, or the leading edge.
There's, there are a few others, um,
uh, who I think also do
this, but he does, he's the,
the leading edge of I get that there's
silicon valley's creating all this kind
of interesting technology.
Um,
and I get that there's these
really powerful commercial
models and want to learn
from them. But when Corey
comes out to silicon valley,
of course he has the interest that every
politician does, which is, you know,
raising money and there's a bunch of
money in order to inform political
campaigns. But he's first, second,
and third questions aren't about
how do I get you to give me a check?
It's how do I learn from you in order to
solve a problem that's critical for the
American people and in particular,
critical for the people who may be being
left out, uh, but all people as well.
And so, you know, whether I'd,
his focus is on, you know,
we have a really serious problem with
mass incarceration or whether the,
the challenges, um, you know,
what do we do? Um, in order to,
you know, kind of have a good
foreign policy, you know,
any of these questions he starts with,
what do I learn from you that can then
help me figure out how to help us be
better, uh, as a, as a country. And,
and then of course, you
know, when you, you know,
if he ends up with alignment and he says,
look, you know, can you help me with x, Y,
and z? At that point, he
speaking your language, um, and,
uh,
and as understood and has asked you to
participate and helping being a good
citizen. And you know, uh,
if we could have a more
senators like, uh, you know,
Senator Booker, Corey my friend, uh,
I think the world would
be a much better place.
Yeah, totally agreed. He's,
he's exceptional at asking
incisive questions. Uh,
and not just for the sake
of asking the questions,
but for actually listening to
the answers. Yup. Michael, uh,
what is the book that you have
given most as a gift or books?
We suddenly actually
reach book with a been a,
because Nosha at the startup of you
and uh, why, why have
you chosen that book?
Uh,
it,
it just has a lot of principles in it
for young people right out of college or
kind of in the middle of their
20s and such to think about
how to pursue their careers.
Got It. And what, and a,
what would be your will be your second
book if you had to pick a second,
uh,
well,
to young people,
I often give them a simple book you've
probably heard about called getting
things done. David Allen,
combine that with, uh,
the seven habits of highly
effective people because I
think the former helps you
to actually to,
to action and the ladder healthier side,
which actions to actually,
you know, take. So I mentor
a lot of young people. Um,
and I think those two books
together are probably good for them.
Wonderful. Yeah, we're going to,
we're going to dive into quest Virginia
second because I want to make sure that
we covered that. Uh, read.
What about yourself, the,
the book or books that you've given
most as gifts besides the ones that, uh,
that you've been involved with directly?
Yes. Well, obviously I tend to give out
my two books to start off with you and the
alliance,
uh,
a fair amount of partially because you
can sign it and you can make it very
personalized and it becomes a very,
you know, a personal touch gift. Uh,
I'd say the two books that I
have recently most given out, um,
one of them is a conscious business
by Fred Kaufman and Fred is,
I think to some degree the modern high
spiritual priest of capitalists business.
Uh, his whole kind of thread is to say,
actually, in fact, how you can, uh,
express business and capitalism as
a spiritual practice of compassion.
Um, and I, you know, he, you know, it's a,
it's a book that opens with a discussion
of Aristotle and, you know, not, not, not,
you wouldn't be surprised, be surprised
on a business book. So that's one.
And then the other one is
Sapiens by Yuval Harari,
which is a very grand, it's one of
the ones I've read most recently.
Um, a grand theory of humanity
and kind of how does the,
is cognition work? Um, and I
don't know enough to know, like,
is it really deep scholarly work or not?
But it's exactly the kind of broad
thinking book that I think should be more
and, you know, a general consciousness.
And Michael, you, uh, you
mentioned mentoring. I think
this is a good segue. Uh,
could you please describe a questbridge,
uh,
and what questbridge does
because of course, that's,
that's a common thread that ties
everyone on this call together. Uh,
reed being,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but a chair of the advisory board,
I'm,
I'm one participant on the advisory board
and very honored to be part of that.
But could you describe a,
and you of course,
are one of the cofounders of questbridge.
Could you describe for P for folks, uh,
what it is a questbridge does and
some of the results or numbers?
Sure. I'll describe what it does and when
the problem it solves as well. Um, and,
and you said Ruby does the head of
the advisory board and we've really
appreciated your, her
both with Tim. So, uh,
questbridge is on one level simply a
common application for super smart low
income kids heading to top schools
like Princeton and Yale and swap mourn,
Emerson such,
um,
you can apply to other schools for
free whether application online, um,
the schools help to offset the costs of
the pool so we don't have to raise a lot
of money and kin of focus on execution.
Uh,
the scale is reached, um,
insignificant and whereabouts, um, at,
at some schools, about half
of their diversity. And we
put in more low income, uh,
kids in all the other nonprofits in
the country actually all combined. Um,
but there are a lot more out there.
And,
and the interesting thing in America that
people don't know is there's actually
no shortage of smart low
income kids to use up.
All of these kinds of
wonderful of financial aid
opening schools can afford to
pay a full tuition award. Um, it's just,
they simply aren't
handing in applications.
And so we're trying to make that
process simpler. But in real numbers,
we had over 140 kids
accepted to Yale last year,
over 110 my were excepted.
Um,
the majority of those accepted
would actually go. Uh,
so I'm the one hand, our numbers
are large. On the other hand,
we've probably gone from,
from finding and having them apply like
one in 14 of the qualified kids to one
in nine. Um, you could fail, uh, several,
uh,
times over every top school with smart,
qualified going to come back at Demec
kids for all the financial aid openings.
And uh, I'm sorry, go ahead. I didn't
mean to interrupt. If you had more there,
but I,
oh no, I didn't. My wife
and I had been doing this.
Now I'm in some form for
about 20 years or so and uh,
are, are, are hitting a good scale,
but our Brooklyn people like we had
another is to try to increase our scale.
And also now we have about 8,000
students in our schools. You know,
how do you bring them into the corporate
world in like medical schools and
things also?
And, uh, the, uh, for
those interested, uh, the,
the New York Times,
The Wall Street Journal's had some,
some excellent feature pieces
recently on questbridge read.
You get asked for you to
participate in different projects,
different startups,
different nonprofits all the time.
What is it about questbridge that
led you to decide to participate,
to contribute to it,
to be part of it?
Well,
it's actually a very similar process to
how I actually make a decision to be an
investor. Um, uh, not 100%, but close,
which is, you know, roughly speaking,
I think the mission of life is
how do you maximize humanity, uh,
the expression of human potential.
Uh,
our consciousness, our, uh, our, our,
our sense of ethics and ethos
are ways of being with together.
And when you look at
Questbridge, you'd say, well,
here is actually in fact one very
intelligent system design for that because
the, you know, the way that you can
change a life of this high talent,
low income kid by providing a
path and an understanding and a,
an a way of succeeding through a strong
college is not only a way to change a
life, uh, but also to change the
world, uh, because you know, those,
that not only did they change
their own lives, but then they,
they model for others, they can
essentially get back to the community. Uh,
and also then folks who,
you know,
benefit from elite universities,
have the knowledge and understanding
and compassion to, you know,
kind of what are the,
the challenges for lower income and can
help participate in a really positive
way. So a part of, you know, um,
I think if anything, you know, Michael's
being, uh, you know, kind of, uh,
socially, uh, EPT and discreet and not,
you know, kind of saying, look, it's a,
it's an application but not all as
an application. It's a community.
It's a community, helps, uh,
helps those kids succeed through college
and then connect with the world around
them at large. And so it's, it's, uh,
it was a very quick and easy
decision to, uh, to join and help.
And so, Michael, what I'd
like to do is just give a,
as a,
an example of the type of thing that gets
me excited about questbridge and fee.
Please feel free to correct me because I
know this is just a small part or maybe
one example, but for those
people listening, I mean I'm,
I'm involved with a number of
nonprofits, but I, it, I try to apply,
like read the same level of scrutiny and
high expectations to nonprofits that I
would to for profits. And that's it.
It turns out to be very challenging.
Um, but in the case of Questbridge,
Reid mentioned earlier,
part of strategy being
solving the easiest,
most valuable problem.
And I think part of that is identifying
of course the right problem.
And, uh, as you mentioned, Michael,
there's a lot of money out there.
There is a lot of money.
Uh,
beat at colleges will give students more
than $300,000 each to go to college.
The, the, one of the issues is
simply the lack of applications.
These kids don't apply oftentimes,
and they may not have the social support.
It may not even enter their minds to
apply. So how do you solve that problem?
Because a lot of people are trying to
solve the wrong problem by throwing more
money at the problem, doing it too late,
and they miss the window of opportunity.
And so what, what really caught my
attention first about questbridge was,
uh,
just one small example,
which was in these communities where
they may not even be thinking of applying
to college, uh, doing, for instance,
an Ipad giveaway or a giveaway of some
type and the application or form to sign
up for this giveaway potentially,
uh,
and when just so happens to also be a
standardized application that you've
convinced 36 top schools to accept as,
as college applications.
And so these kids are incentivized in a
way that is kind of culturally relevant
to them. And then they get a letter in
the mail saying, Hey, by the way, uh,
Princeton University here, we'd like to
offer you a full ride for four years.
And it's just such an elegant solution.
And it's such an example for
me at least of putting in a,
getting a very large result for a,
uh,
a small input, a small intervention.
Um, and that's why, you know,
I've been so excited to,
uh,
to talk about questbridge and I've been
looking forward to this interview for
many other reasons also. But to try
to showcase it for people to say like,
not all hard problems
have to be hard to solve.
You just have to really surgically
focus in the right place. Um,
so I'd love to ask just as it
relates to Questbridge, uh,
what's, what if for people who want to
learn more, where should they go? And,
uh,
there,
there are many people listening to
this show who are perhaps like me,
have recognized how they were set
down a very fortunate path by having
educational opportunities that are
not available to everyone. Um, so for,
for people who might want
to contribute to such a,
you know, an effective Archimedes
lever like questbridge, you know,
where should they go and,
and how might they be able to help?
Sure. Um, I,
I think to clarify the problem to so
your listeners can understand it. Um,
the, uh, before questbridge,
about three quarters of the diversity
withdrawn from only fifth Patina,
urban areas in the country.
So you were more likely to hear about
heading to a school like Swarthmore,
if you had a 2.8 from Harlem and if you
had a 4.0 from a lot of other areas in
the country.
So questbridge recruits that at uh,
you know, in New York, in
Chicago like other people do,
but also in like buffalo and Syracuse
and other areas of the country,
um,
in defense of the kids,
it's not intuitive at a school and give
you $300,000 for free of course. So,
so,
so to get their application data quest
is unique in that we have our own kind of
application data set. So as
you said, if we create, um,
a prize or if others you
wanted to help us do that, uh,
we've had a lot of success in attracting
applicants to fulfill out a college
application for a proposition
unrelated to the application itself.
Um, so if it's a student
who wants to get involved,
they can simply go to our
website@questbridge.org.
We have an application actually open
now for, um, this falls application cycle.
We have access to about half
a billion dollars of, uh,
financial aid from our
universities. And we'd like to, um,
uh,
you know,
harvest more of America's latent talent
from areas that we haven't reached
earlier. Um, I,
I'd say to your listeners to make sure
that your local high school actually uses
our application and that I'm
only about a third of the,
the high schools in the country
have handed applications in. Um,
and then for people who would like
to create their own intervention,
let's say for low income kids wanting
to do maths and science of low income
women are low income people from
the south or almost any interest,
they can even reach out to
me, to me directly. And uh,
uh, on your, uh, body,
you can feel free to put my email address
if you'd like to. Okay, wonderful.
And would you like to give that out now
or would you prefer this one? Yeah, yeah,
it's Michael, um, uh, at quest bridge.org.
Great.
And by prizes,
you mean people could offer some type
of what w what might uprise look like?
Yeah, it's really odd. It could be,
it could be nonmonetary
like we'd like to say, um,
you know, have a, a leadership award at
like the White House Strip something. Um,
but it can get simple as we ran a pilot
for native Americans where we give away
a 20 laptops cooking the actual
university application up to the uprise
application and we grew from
having only 34 applicants one year,
two or 350,
um,
the year after that.
So for everyone listening, I just want to
really encourage you, I, I am very, very,
uh,
I have a very,
very tight filter tightness filter when
it comes to working with nonprofits and
uh, this, this one is worth your time. So
I would just encourage you to look at it.
Um,
forget about the label nonprofit as an
intervention that can better humanity. Um,
as, as reed mentioned, this is,
this is one of the rare gems out
there in my opinion. And you know,
other organizations that I've worked
with, like donors choose, for instance,
Charles Best is a huge fan of questbridge.
And he said,
the first thing he said to me when I
mentioned a few years ago that Michael,
you and I connected, he said,
that is an excellent choice.
That is an awesome choice.
Um,
so people check out questbridge.org and
you can reach Michael if you'd like to
discuss, uh, collaborating in
some way. michael@questbridge.org.
So I'll just ask one more question guys.
It'll take a one or two minutes
and that is, um, let's, uh, let's,
let's start with you Michael.
If you could have one billboard
anywhere that said anything,
what would it say and where would it be?
I probably have people do what you do
to Jim. Pick something you're afraid
of every day and in kind of go after it.
And uh,
I'd put that on kind of peoples
a way to work I suppose.
What about yourself read?
Well,
this is kind of a I a funny reflex,
but was just something I
would thinking about recently.
I think I would take the
billboard in Washington DC.
I think I would target
congresspeople and I say,
have you worked with someone
across the aisle today?
Because what matters is
not partisan conflict,
but how do we govern our country
to actually have a better future
here, here. Definitely.
Last question guys.
Do you have any ask or request
for my audience? Uh, read,
we can start with you.
And then where can people find you online?
Where can they ping you on
social networks, et Cetera?
Well,
on social networks it's very easy.
There's this service that maybe a few
people have heard of called Linkedin, uh,
you know, find double there. Um,
I'd say two things. Uh, one is,
uh, you know, I would also
echo the fact that, uh,
questbridge is a scale, uh, way of, of,
of changing the world for the better
of actually making us more of the,
you know,
kind of for us in the u s the American
dream in terms of the ability for,
uh, for talented low income
youth to actually, you know,
uh, live in a meritocracy.
So I think it's a awesome,
and whatever way you can support
whether it's contributing or helping or,
you know, pointing out the right
talented young kid added is all great.
And then the second is,
you know,
last year I published a book
called the alliance. Uh,
your audience tends to be highly
literate, not a surprise given you, uh,
and so in as much as they're
thinking about how has the nature of,
of employment and how has the nature of,
of um,
of the relationship between an
employee in a company changing,
I think it might be something that
could stimulate a few thoughts.
Definitely. And I have a copy of that
book at home and as f everybody, uh,
highly worth the read, uh,
so highly recommended there.
Well Gentlemen, uh, this,
this has been wonderful.
I've really enjoyed the conversation
and for everybody listening,
I will put everything we discussed in
the show notes so we'll have links to
questbridge, the book recommendations
and so on. Uh, just got a four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and click
on podcast to find that. And,
uh, guys, I really appreciate
you making the time. This was,
this was a lot of fun and I have pages
and pages of notes just for myself.
Tim, I'll always a pleasure
and always an honor.
Thank you for the conversation to
all right guys. Until next time,
thank you and everyone else. Until
next time. Thank you for listening.
This episode is brought to you by 99
your one stop shop for all things graphic
design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything
from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that
led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York
Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers
from around the world and here's how it
works. Whether you need a t
shirt, a business card, a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and
designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches
and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an
original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you
who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things
that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime, if you want
to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers,
as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by
a new sponsor. So listen up folks.
This is a good one because have you ever
wanted to be as powerful as a bullet
wearing Ninja from 1980s movie or as
flamboyant as big gay Al Big Al in south
park or as sleek as a black panther
and the Amazon on the hunt wealth?
There's great because I've been testing
this product that you wrap around your
genitals and it makes you feel like a
superhero and it is called [inaudible].
That's for the last two to three weeks
traveling with underwear from these guys
and they are comfy.
I got to tell you,
it feels like a Geisha has given your
groin a hug. And it's not just for dudes.
But if you go to me undies.com forward
slash Tim, that's m, e, e, u, n, d,
I e s.com,
forward slash Tim,
you can see all of the underwear
that I've been wearing.
There's some pretty ridiculous ones. And
uh, I will also highlight my favorite,
you'll probably be able to guess which
it is these underwear made from micro
model, which is extruded from Austrian
beechwood trees in the Alps. Yes. Fancy.
And it's two times softer than cotton,
scientifically tested.
Is it the Calamata method
developed in Kyoto? You know,
this Japanese very crafty and uh, I
will say a few things. Number one,
if you go to [inaudible]
dot com forward slash Tim,
you get to see all of these spectacular
underwear that I'd been wearing and I am
a bit of an underwear connoisseur,
socks, fashion sense with sweat pants,
not so much underwear.
I understand.
So check them out and if you go to
[inaudible] dot com forward slash him,
you'll also be able to see lots of hot
ladies wearing BMDS female underwear.
And that's just a lot of goodness for
both the men and the women out there.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim,
I love these unaware and uh,
I want it to be packing tonight,
probably six to 12 pair to take
with me to Australia. They're great.
Check them out. [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.